uh your first your first concerts yeah
so what was that like our first concert
um
oh gosh
I feel really bad for saying this like
uh we had a meeting with our boss and
our boss was like you're always gonna
remember your first concert because like
this is a life-changing experience that
sounds really threatening
you'll remember this it's gonna be such
a magical moment sure I was so nervous I
don't remember a single thing so every
single time like every anniversary that
our group has we always have this
interview where it's like you know you
like look back at your past what do you
remember are you not your first concert
I'm like I don't remember a single thing
that was so nervous
I don't remember anything but um our
first live actually sprained my ankle oh
[__] yeah I drink God uh it was like an
open rehearsal where people could watch
on the first uh number I fell oh [__]
sprained my ankle oh my God so um that
part I remember but everything else I
don't know wait so how many did you have
to continue with the rest of the
rehearsals yeah I didn't even know how
bad it was sprained but like the next
day I went to the doctors and they gave
me crutches
the adrenaline and everything got me
going yeah yeah like damaging it more
yeah
but my uh it was my left leg but it was
already kind of screwed up with um
figure skating for so long yeah so
that's one thing I wanted to get into
like how did you get into the figure
skating thing figure skating there was
this Japanese Drama called
um
and my dad was so into it right and he
was like do you want to go figure
skating tomorrow like this the next day
he saw an answer yeah so we went and
apparently I was really good like I got
scouted by the coach
so I started but then again the problem
was I was so bad at like you know the
public eye it just wasn't my thing so
the reason I quit was because
um I had a panic attack after my short
program
my last competition I was like this
thing is just not for me so like because
that happened still to this day I don't
know how I'm an idol still I'm
performing it yeah it sounds like this
is the worst lineup yeah it's it's funny
because it's like considering how
nervous you are on stage and how as you
say you're not good on stage like you've
managed to find yourself in situations
where you have to perform on stage yeah
you know so I pretend that when I'm an
idol I just pretend that I'm an
undercover spy
anyway so explain the thought process of
that right so you know like as somebody
who wanted to be a voice like a voice
actor only yeah and you know who didn't
really want to perform on stage if you
think that you're a spy you know and
you're like I'm only doing this like
this isn't my job like I'm only here to
know what happens behind closed doors
you know so I can experience what like
other people can't see you know even the
documentaries won't show you I feel
really cool while doing it
you are literally the definition of fake
it yeah that's crazy that is that is
impressive how long between like you you
know you're getting the audition uh was
there between like doing your first live
and Performing for the first time
only like six months it was even before
we dated we had our first live so yeah
it really wasn't that long okay so after
this first performance did you like have
fans right away
um yes because
the producer was of course so people
yeah and you know Sony music
it was overwhelming I was like people
who like me that's a first I'm not used
to that there's even like fans uh
Japanese fans as well right it must be
so bizarre thinking like damn I I just
showed up here and I yeah you guys like
me yeah but like I felt really happy
because again my goal was to be somebody
like sugita Tomoka as it was to me yeah
so I felt really happy when people were
like you motivated me to pursue my dream
as well you know like you make me really
happy that makes me really happy as well
I'm curious like what the training
process for an idol is you said there
was like six months like what is the
process between you becoming the eye are
you becoming an idol and you know doing
your life
well because majority of our members
were still in school and ha almost half
weren't even from Tokyo so we only had
lessons during Saturday and Sunday okay
and it was like the full day we would
have dance practice and also voice
acting lessons as well and singing
lessons and we would have like acting
tests on Christmas day yeah
um
happy Christmas
have a drumstick recite the entirety of
Pulp Fiction right now yeah but but I
mean I guess because we had an upcoming
anime coming up and
um we also had characters but those
characters weren't really official yet
right right you know so we had to have
like a lot of acting tests to see like
who would fit which character so
everybody was like really serious about
it but I was like really on Christmas
day don't you guys have families
isn't that big of a thing
yeah
we would have really stressful acting
tests and they would give you like a
report card what does an acting test
look like in Japan so um for our group
it was reciting
it's like a tongue twister in Japan like
a lot of voice actors do it in voice
acting in school I saw them all
practicing tongue twisters it's like a
10 minute tongue twister it's really
really long yeah I just wouldn't
associate your quality to act with your
ability to do a tongue twister I just
feel like that's I feel like um
especially in anime though like tongue
twisters are really important yeah right
um especially if you have to like speak
fast and make the enunciation sound
perfect and natural as well like I think
tongue twisters is a great way of like
kind of practicing enunciation
especially yeah I could see how it's
practicing enunciation but I wouldn't in
my mind I wouldn't think that I wouldn't
want to be judged on my ability to act
based on if I did like red truck [__]
blue truck
do you mean red leather yellow leather
like whatever this is like a bunch you
say like it's just so it seems so
arbitrary yeah you can kind of be like
no you can't act why uh well he failed
on the tongue he didn't say Peter Piper
properly and uh you know she's sold she
sells somewhere else
I just feel like it'd be such an
arbitrary decision but I guess it makes
sense as well and the way you described
it yeah just can't imagine it it was
based on like how loud your voice was as
well while you did those so you had to
like shout it yeah because you know in
Japanese yeah like how you know how you
yeah right say things it's really
important I guess especially in the
voice acting industry so and you're like
your tongue twister and those things
were like just the basic things that you
had to be perfect at my feeling is the
opposite problem when I was doing more
people were too loud
less is more yeah what do you mean
people sometimes get they emote too much
on lines right they get two lines a
shouting line but you're not trying to
blow the mic out you're trying to shout
not not be Vault like there's a
difference between shouting and just
having a lot of volume yeah and those
two things are very different it's like
it's like the way I'd like to describe
it is like you know sometimes your dad
would shout at you but it wasn't loud at
you but you knew you were a [__] yeah
it's kind of like that it's like you he
was shouting and it depends on the dad
right yeah the intensity the quieter he
was the more [__] I was here exactly
like laying intensity without relying on
volume yeah yeah kind of a concept that
you have to I think this world is like
an interesting I guess like cultural
difference with like Japanese acting
versus English acting whereas like you
know a lot of like say like Hollywood
movies you know there's a lot of like
scenes where it's very quiet and very
like you know expressive but in a very
like uh subtle way yeah you know like to
the point where like you'd watch like a
Matthew McConaughey movie and you'd be
like I actually can't make out what the
[__] he's saying because he's so quiet
and so mumbly whereas with a lot of like
Japanese any stuff like not not just
Anime but like even live action stuff
it's all about like projecting it's more
like a stage play than like how you were
doing a movie right I mean I guess
that's just like what you described is
basically just a lot of like anime voice
acting which is I guess more over the
top yeah kind of motive than you would
say get in a Hollywood film because it's
so weird seeing live-action Japanese
actors you know in like a live-action TV
drama because sometimes I see the way
they act and I'm like they are not
acting like people they're acting like
anime yeah yeah yeah totally I think
that's why one of the most critically
acclaimed films came out of Japan's most
recent memory was um what's that one
with the where they were driving around
a lot and husband died or something it
was I forgot what it's called it was
like it was literally every day I guess
because it was way more of a subtle and
way more uh yeah a lot more toned down
and more yeah it's called I think it was
nominated for an Oscar I think yeah well
I I guess that like you know this is
going completely off topic now but on
the topic of this that's why I really
enjoyed the voice acting of B Stars yes
because it will it felt way more natural
and way more it was almost like live
action you know they weren't speaking
over the top even if there were some
really intense scenes there it felt way
more like a western Hollywood film in
terms of like its approach to waxing and
this approach to like and then I feel
especially with B stars like when that
got translated to the English dub as
well I feel like the dark voice actors
just sounded so much more natural than a
lot of other like dubs that I've heard
because it's like the nature of the show
already was like you know the fact that
the whole thing was Mo capped and the
actors were actually mocapped while
doing the lines and everything so it's
like it just felt more like oh I'm
actually like listening to people talk
rather than like anime characters in a
weird way I don't know yeah like out of
curiosity when you were doing the voice
acting school and the voice acting
training was there any kind of like
lessons or training in terms of like
actually getting into a character as
opposed to just kind of like emoting and
saying lines
um it was there was actually no acting
at all for the first couple of months
well I mean okay
did you have much of an acting
background in the States before never I
I took acting as an elective in middle
school for one trimester yeah and I
didn't get a single line
I was just there
I was the bunny c
yeah so yeah America go to Japan
there was like absolutely no way for me
to practice acting before I came here so
I would have to like make up my own ways
of practicing acting is very clicky in
the west at least when I was growing if
I wanted I remember I wanted to try and
do it and it was already the theater
kids were already well established who
the theater kids were yeah it was like
you cannot
yeah I think that happens a lot but
um at least uh you're able to make it
work yeah